good morning thank you for joining us um
i suppose you want to start with an
apology to the british public
uh well um we moved quickly uh in
response to the vaccine obviously this
report has just come out so we want to
look at it and consider it that's why
we've also got an inquiry to ensure that
where there are lessons to learn we do
so but we followed throughout the
scientific advice
we got the vaccine deployed extremely
quickly we protected our nhs from the
surge of cases but of course if there
are lessons to learn we're keen to do so
keen to start with an apology though i
would have thought well no we followed
the scientific advice we protected
we followed the scientific advice we
protected the nhs twenty thousand lives
needlessly lost because you didn't lock
down a week earlier and you don't want
to apologize well the issue of the
timing of the lockdown was based on the
evidence and the scientific advice at
the time the concern was if we'd locked
down too soon there wouldn't be a
willingness to lock down for a long
period of time but it's right okay that
we look
in the inquiry at what lessons there are
to learn
and ensure that we learn from them no
apology that um we were told by the then
health secretary that there was a
protective ring around care homes and we
know that that not to be the case
well the decisions were taken on the
evidence and the scientific advice at
the time they were taken to protect the
nhs but the government took decisions at
the time based on the scientific advice
it received but those scientists
themselves were operating in a very new
environment where they themselves were
learning about the pandemic i don't
understand why you don't want to
apologize well there are lessons to
learn but the point is that we took
decisions based on the science there
were 20 000 unnecessary deaths in the
united kingdom many of them elderly
people and you don't want to apologize
what i'm saying kay is did we take
decisions based on the scientific
evidence we were protected what did we
say
did we save lives through deploying the
vaccine at pace far quicker than many
comparable countries 20 000 needless
deaths according to the report you don't
need to go through the whole you know
hefty report in order to know that they
it says that twenty thousand people died
needlessly many of them elderly and
infirm
are you not sorry about that well this
is why we're taking decisions for
example around uh
there will be lessons and of course
where there's lessons we're keen to take
that on board the fundamental point
within your question is are there
lessons for us to learn from what
happened at the pandemic and the answer
to that is we will learn the lessons
that's not my question with respect what
i'm saying is that 20 000 families
watching this morning probably
um lost a loved one uh they couldn't go
to the funerals because either they
weren't allowed at all or that there was
an extended family and they couldn't all
go
and we saw
a young man who was lowered into the
ground and his family couldn't be there
and they had to watch it on zoom um 20
000 times that happened needlessly
how can you not say you're sorry well
that is heartbreaking that impact on
families that impact uh in terms of
people's humans is heartbreaking and i
think all of us feel that all of us have
friends and neighbours
who were in that situation i didn't want
to apologize on behalf of the government
joining us now is the shadow financial
secretary to the treasury james murray
mr murray good morning do you think
that uh the minister should have
apologized
i think the government needs to take
responsibility
and that's across the piece you know
there is going to be so many lessons to
learn uh from what the government did
during covert and what they failed to do
and you know what we've seen in this
report is is damning i think a lot more
is going to come out with the public
inquiry um and i think there will be a
whole number of ways in which the
government needs to take responsibility
for what happened you know i remember
back last year okay we didn't know how
it was going to pan out but we could see
some of the things happening in care
homes for instance where
people were not being protected in care
homes the ppe just wasn't there i knew
that as a constituency mp as well as at
the time a member of the health select
committee and we saw the fact that
people were not being protected we saw
people being discharged into care homes
and we saw what happened there that's
just one example but across the piece um
the families of all of those who died
need the government to take
responsibility for their actions
we were told that if we had locked down
a week earlier then many many thousands
of lives would have been saved kyostama
at the time supported when we locked
down and is it also an opportunity
perhaps for you this morning to
apologize on behalf of labor
i think everyone will reflect on what
happened during the outbreak and if you
see what happened as things went on it
became clear that we need to we need to
take action quickly and decisively to
get on top of the
the virus and as we saw toward the end
of the summer uh kirsten called for a
circuit breaker uh to try and halt the
rise in cases then and the government
prevaricated again so
at the beginning of the of the outbreak
you might have said well it's new people
are still
getting their heads around and how it
works and i'm sure the government will
say that but it was very clear
as the outbreak went on and has become
clear how the virus transmitted and how
the virus got throughout society
the government was still reluctant still
held back from taking those decisive
measures quick enough and so do you
remember it was toward the end of summer
september
last year when kirsten would call for
that a short circuit break the
government held back things got worse
and at every stage what we saw both in
terms of the health responses and as
well the economic responses or the
financial support that people have
needed
the government was too slow and too late
at every turn
any answer to my question
as i said i'm sure there will be a lot
of consideration about
what people said and and how things were
were handled but the government
ultimately has to take responsibility
for what they did and what novel is
crucially what they did not do
yeah but as as i pointed out um zakir
was supporting what um the government
had decided to do with lockdown in the
early stages as a result many thousands
of people died who would not have done
if we'd locked down a week earlier i
don't understand why politicians don't
want to say to my viewers um we are
sorry for every death
well every death is is awful and
shocking and i know that as a
constituent cmp um as well as someone on
the shadow front bench i think what's
really crucial though is that the
government
has the information they have access to
the scientific advice they also have
access to wider information about what's
going on and it is up to them to take
decisions about what about how to
respond to the pandemic and now as we
begin to look back they need to take
responsibility
i don't understand why story seems to be
the hardest word for politicians on my
program this morning
what i'm saying is the government needs
to take responsibility for the decisions
i get that and i and i challenge them on
that i'm asking whether labour wants to
accept any responsibility whatsoever
about the fact that we didn't lock down
a week earlier you didn't hold the prime
minister's feet to the flame in fact
your leader supported him at that time
you must be in some way sorry
well actually i think if you if you
remember the timing uh the the first
lockdown came before kirsten became a
leader of the party that's
remembering that correctly um but
actually if you look at when kirsten
was the leader later in the summer uh
when there was
uh the after the end of the summer and
we were looking at how the pandemic
might pan out into the autumn and
kirsten were called for a circuit break
and the government did not do that you
know he was very clear that we need to
act quickly and we need to make sure we
have that circuit break to prevent
uh infections from spiraling
who was leader at the time correcting me
on who was leader at the time as opposed
to saying yeah
these people died and they wouldn't have
done if we'd lock down a week earlier
and we as the opposition have to accept
some responsibility for not pushing the
government to a lock down a week earlier
when that's what we were being told not
only in the uk but in other countries
around the world surely there must be
some sense of wanting to apologize to
those uh 20 000 families who lost their
loved ones unnecessarily surely
well i think everyone will think about
what they were saying and doing at the
time i was a member of the health select
committee myself at the time and i
remember us looking at the evidence
coming in
and being concerned about what the
governments response was i think this is
a really important point though which is
that the government had access to the
scientific information they had an
overview of the wider situation going on
they could see what was happening in
other countries and they decided to lock
down too late and
importantly to add to that as well it
wasn't just the beginning it's also a
pattern that repeated itself you know
i'm sure the government will say that at
the beginning of the outbreak people did
not know exactly how this virus was
going to spread and what was going to
happen but as time went on it became
very clear
that we needed to act quickly and
decisively to get on top of infections
and that is not what happened um when we
went into the into the autumn both in
terms of the health measures and in
terms of financial support available to
people
so labour's not sorry
at all in any way for their part in the
lockdown not happening a week earlier
as i say the government were
in charge sorry i don't get why you
can't just say sorry it's it's
staggering to me and staggering to my
viewers i'm sure that you can't just say
we are sorry for any unnecessary deaths
i i think any unnecessary deaths are
shocking and awful and i i've been
advocating on behalf of constituents of
mine um who lost family members um
during the outbreak as well as my role
on the shadow front bench what i'm
saying is that the government needs to
take responsibility
for what happened they need to make sure
they take responsibility for what
happened in terms of lockdown and as
well as what happened in care homes and
other parts of society that were
affected uh by what happened during the
outbreak
okay thank you for joining us on the
program this morning thank